if Selena Gomez had an erwan smoothie
like some other celebrities we know she
would keep it real as no I don't
want people to do that though so as a
dietitian let me show you what I would
make if I was partnering up with Selena
to make an erwan smoothie so we're gonna
do banana mango got some soaked cashews
here a little vanilla protein powder
hemp hearts because I'm involved
obviously and coconut milk she's gonna
be creamy
thank you
some tahin coconut milk for the rimmer
let's do it oh yeah check
that out all right Selena let's recap we
got protein in the protein powder and
hemp herbs healthy fats in those hemp
hearts coconut and the cashews lesson
fiber in all those things as well as our
fruit of course a little spice for good
measure
air one I'll take a cut